ce second débat de ce sens public
direction les États-Unis pour comprendre
l'incroyable capacité de Donald Trump à
résister à ses déboires judiciaires cet
après-midi on a assisté à la lecture
tient des chefs d'accusation dans l'état
de Géorgie où vous le savez la justice
reproche à l'ancien président d'avoir
tenté frauduleusement de renverser le
résultat de la présidentielle en tout il
y a quatre procédures pénales en cours
pourtant il caracole toujours dans les
sondages pour l'instant on voit mal qui
chez les républicains pourraient
contester son leadership la stratégie de
Donald Trump avec Flora sauvage
30 dollars le t-shirt 20 dollars la
tasse en quelques heures la photographie
d'identité judiciaire de Donald Trump a
été décliné sur tous les supports Trump
est un génie en matière de marketing je
suis sûr qu'il avait anticipé ce moment
ce n'est pas comme si il avait été
surpris par le fait qu'il allait être
pris en photo son équipe devait savoir
que cela allait se produire et ils ont
évidemment planifié en conséquence
reconnaissant que c'était une énorme
opportunité pour lui de s'approprier ce
moment visage fermé sourcils froncés
l'ex locataire de la Maison Blanche
mettant scène ses déboires judiciaires
pour financer ses frais de justice pris
en photo lors de son incarcération
express dans une prison d'Atlanta le 24
août Donald Trump est inculpé pour avoir
tenté d'inverser le résultat de
l'élection présidentielle américaine de
2020 dans l'état de Géorgie il s'agit du
quatrième dossier pénal dans lequel
l'ancien président est poursuivi Donald
Trump est aussi accusé à New York de
paiement suspects à une ancienne actrice
porno et de pression
voilà pour résoudre ce paradoxe apparent
j'accueille loricaine tombe bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes maître de conférence
à l'Université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines chroniqueur
magazine Rolling Stones et ça nous amène
à ce livre qu'on va citer même si on en
parlera pas Rock n' road trip 1000
chansons de l'Alabama Wyoming coécrit
avec Julien Grosso qui sort aux éditions
Hors Collection là le 21 septembre
j'accueille elisachell bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue aux accueillir vous êtes
professeur de sciences politiques à
l'Université Paris Nanterre et
rédactrice en chef de la revue politique
américaine
Idris face à ci bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi professeur de
droit public à l'Université Paris
Panthéon Assas constitutionnalie
spécialiste de droits américains on a
également avec nous en duplex Olivier
Python qui est avocat en droit public
américain bonsoir Olivier python auteur
de ce livre bonsoir
de l'Amérique aux éditions plomb
évidemment Mathieu croissanto est resté
à mes côtés je commence en rappel quand
même que Donald Trump on vient de voir
dans le sujet est accusé alors là je
vais prendre les inculpations on va dire
au pénal d'avoir acheté le silence d'une
actrice porno avec l'argent de sa
campagne d'avoir emporté des cartons de
dossiers sensibles à son départ de la
Maison Blanche d'avoir une
responsabilité dans l'insurrection
contre le Capitole d'avoir tenté de
changer le résultat de la présidentielle
dans l'état de Géorgie on l'a surnommé
le candidat délinquant le week-endon
c'est c'est à chaque fois moi les bras
mentons c'est évidemment inédit dans
l'histoire récentes il y a pas des il y
a pas d'équivalent à ce point là non il
y a eu un temps le Watergate ça nous
rajeunit pas mais c'était bien moindre
et ça a fait démissionner quand même le
président Nixon en 74
mais à ce point non on dépasse des
lignes rouges à chaque fois mais depuis
2015 avec Trump c'est pas quelque chose
de nouveau donc il y a une question qui
est de savoir si on s'habitue à se
franchissement continu de ligne rouge et
que donc ça normalise un certain nombre
le comportement et l'autre question
c'est est-ce que ça normalise ce
comportement pour lui a priori oui parce
que ces électeurs en tout cas sa base
n'y voit pas vraiment de à redire tout
est un complot ou est-ce que ça
normalise et moi je pense que non pour
les autres candidats c'est-à-dire est-ce
que un républicain ou un autre des ou un
démocrates qui serait mouillé dans un
scandale quelconque de Luther ou de elle
pourrait s'en sortir facilement à la
Trump quoi oui et je pense pas que ce
soit le cas je pense qu'il y a vraiment
quelque chose de très personnel sur lui
et son rapport à son public et que pour
l'instant ça marche il y a pas de raison
que ça arrête de marcher à ce point là
on verra après sur les indépendants si
ça continue bien sûr sur les électeurs
indépendants et sur leur vote et puis
aussi et vous allez commencer à
l'aborder sur le on va dire la question
de l'affaiblissement ou non de la
démocratie américaine on y reviendra en
détail un peu plus tard mais ils
achètent il y a ces quatre dossiers au
pénal dont on vient de parler mais je
voudrais bien que vous nous parliez
aussi de il y a deux dossiers aux civils
c'est intéressant de les rappeler parce
que tout ça il va y avoir un impact on
va dire en termes de calendrier
judiciaire et électoral expliquez-nous
oui tout à fait en plus de ces quatre
affaires que tout le monde connaît il y
a une autre affaire qui va être jugée à
partir de d'octobre concernant des
fausses déclarations il a surestimer son
patrimoine pour obtenir des prêts et des
assurances à tarif préférentiel donc ça
ça va quand même durer deux mois et au
mois de janvier donc le 15 janvier le
jour de l'ouverture du caucus de l'Iowa
alors on réexplique rapidement c'est
quoi c'est le la première élection dans
les primaires
très important et ce même jour là
s'ouvre le procès le deuxième procès
contre hygi Caroll donc le premier il
avait été condamné pour agression
sexuelle on s'en souvient il avait versé
5 millions de dollars de dommages et
intérêts et Jean Carole le réattaque
pour diffamation cette fois et elle
demande des dommages internet deux fois
plus important donc ça sera une
médiatisation supplémentaire de ses
affaires même si
une ville il n'est pas censé comparaître
donc on n'aura pas la saga judiciaire de
Trump quitte son domicile avec les
hélicoptères
je pense qu'il joue maintenant plus une
carte défensive et que s'il ne se
présente pas
s'il ne s'est pas présenté aujourd'hui
même en Géorgie ainsi que ses coécu
accusés à la lecture du chef
d'accusation c'est ça il est plus sur la
défensive il a bien vu que sa stratégie
de victimisation
atteint quand même une certaine limite
et qu'il ne peut pas aller beaucoup plus
loin dans la capitalisation de nouveaux
électeurs sur cette sur ce thème alors
justement la Géorgie cette affaire là
Idrissa si c'est la plus grave peut-être
je pense que c'est effectivement c'est
peut-être la plus grave avec celle du
Capitole c'est-à-dire la deuxième
affaire fédérale celle qui porte sur ce
qui s'est passé en janvier
juridiquement elle est plus complexe que
la faire fédérale donc elle est
potentiellement plus embêtante Donald
Trump mais on regarde du calendrier je
pense que on arrivera pas il y aura pas
de procès avant l'élection parce que là
pourquoi
personne inculpées certains ont fait de
demandes pour que la posture soit
accélérée donc il y aura des procès en
octobre d'autres ont fait des demandes
pour être jugé par des Cours fédérales
donc ça part un peu dans tous les sens
et pour Donald Trump quelque part c'est
un avantage parce que il va faire
différentes quêtes pour retarder la
procédure donc finalement si on a évoqué
les quatre affaires la plus dangereuse
ou les plus dangereuses ce sont les deux
affaires fédérales celles qui pensent
les documents classifiés et celles qui
portent sur en termes de calendrier
judiciaire et électoral oui parce que
dans ces deux affaires la date a été
fixée donc on aura un procès en mars
2024 ça c'est pour la faire du Capitole
finalement 4 mars là aussi
effectivement et l'autre procès pour les
documents classifiés aura lieu en mai
2024 donc c'est ces deux affaires
effectivement qui vont retenir attention
alors sur la Géorgie cette accusation
d'avoir tenté de manipuler le résultat
de l'élection Géorgie ça a valu à Donald
Trump parce que les Américains appellent
le mugshot on l'a vu dans dans le sujet
de de lancement de ce débat tout à
l'heure photo d'identité judiciaire que
vous voyez il a aussitôt mis en scène
cette photo d'identité judiciaire pour
imaginer la cacher au contraire il l'a
il l'a mise en scène publié fait
partager et elle lui aurait on va
graisse conditionnelle rapporter plus de
7 millions de dollars de dons 7 millions
100000 dollars de dons Olivier python
comment je me tourne vers vous une
première fois comment vous expliquer que
cette accumulation d'affaires ne freine
pas Donald Trump ou même au contraire
booste ça campagne auprès des électeurs
républicains
alors d'abord il faut partir d'un
constat qui est un constat que tout le
monde fait aussi bien du côté des
démocrates que du côté des républicains
c'est que la société américaine n'a
jamais été aussi clivée elle n'a jamais
été aussi divisé avec deux camps qui ne
se parlent plus qui se haïssent et qui
s'investit à longueur de d'articles de
prêt ou de ou d'interview dans les
médias en gros si vous voulez dès qu'un
camp va décoder démocrates en
l'occurrence vont porter une accusation
contre Donald Trump ou lorsque la
justice s'empare d'un sujet et que ce
soit aux filles civil et au pénal on a
toujours la même réaction du côté du
cantreum c'est-à-dire victimisation
contre-attaque la meilleure défense
étant toujours la taxe vous remarquez
que ça défense est toujours la même
c'est-à-dire qu'il pousse au paroxysme
l'agressivité et l'attaque contre ses
adversaires et puis troisièmement il les
prend à témoin et c'est peut-être ça qui
représente sa force la plus importante
c'est que
il politise la justice il considère
qu'elle est politisée il faut dire que
le calendrier que vous avez trouvé
justement tous va justement dans le sens
de ce narratif c'est qu'en gros il est
victime d'une cabale et donc il a
tendance à agglomérer si vous voulez à
solidifier sa base la société américaine
est en clivée comme elle l'est vous avez
en gros deux cas de figure et au bout du
compte assez peu de gens qui essayent de
rester raisonnable au milieu les
indépendants mais on verra ce qu'ils
feront vous avez ceux qui sont persuadés
que Donald Trump et coupable et vous
êtes ceux qui sont persuadés que Donald
Trump est victime d'une Kabbale et comme
ces gens ne se parlent plus toute action
justice est immédiatement suivie par une
contre-réaction qui tente à le légitimer
il a aujourd'hui dépasse aujourd'hui les
60 points d'avance sur son principal
poursuivant loin de Santis à l'échelon
des primaires républicaines donc sauf
effectivement accident il devrait
pouvoir
remporter la primaire en tout cas on ne
voit pas comment ça pourrait être
autrement mais surtout tout à fait
judiciaire le renforce systématiquement
il lui fait gagner des sondages dernière
la première affaire avait lieu au 30
mars 2023 et il n'a cessé de progresser
depuis oui effectivement alors justement
démonstration enfin j'apporte de l'eau à
votre moulin avec cette déclaration de
Donald Trump il se réjouit à chaque
nouvelle acte d'accusation là c'était au
lendemain de sa comparution devant un
tribunal à Washington dans l'écoute
chaque fois qu'il dépose d'un acte
d'accusation nous montons en flèches
dans les sondages nous avons besoin d'un
acte d'accusation de plus pour clore
cette élection un seul acte d'accusation
de plus et l'élection est jouée d'avance
personne n'a la moindre chance
elisachell c'est quand même bon c'est la
stratégie de Trump vous avez dit que il
est peut-être en train de les de la
faire évoluer cette stratégie de de
victimisation mais est-ce que c'est pas
aussi on est sur un débat où on essaie
de se poser la question de de l'impact
de finalement de la stratégie Trump sur
cette démocratie américaine qui est
l'une des plus vieilles ou la plus
démocratie au monde c'est aussi la
justice américaine alors certes elle est
politisée on le sait mais c'est aussi la
justice américaine qui perd des points
auprès d'une partie de l'opinion
publique c'est c'est pas neutre en
termes d'impact oui mais Trump se met en
scène depuis le départ quand il a
commencé à parler d'élection volée il y
a quelques années c'était pour pouvoir
se représenter puisque aucun président
américain battu ne s'est représenté il
doit normalement selon les canons
démocratiques admettre sa défaite et
passer la main donc Donald Trump se met
en scène après chaque
nouveau rebondissements ou nouveau à
l'affaire judiciaire il se met en scène
il dit qu'il monte qu'il n'a jamais été
aussi fort donc il faut aussi mettre à
distance qui est la stratégie de
communication de Trump on a beaucoup
parlé de ces 7 millions de dollars
supposant que c'était une somme énorme
faite à partir des mugshots mais
réfléchissons-y un instant
7 millions de dollars si on considère
que ces mugs ces t-shirts etc tous ces
produits dérivés coûtent aller en
moyenne 20 dollars ça veut dire qu'il en
a vendu à les 300 ou 3
donc c'est pas énorme son cœur de fan
quoi d'une certaine
réuni 74 millions de voix sur son nom
donc 350 000 c'est une et encore unité
même pas acheteur donc on est vraiment
sur une minorité de d'inconditionnel qui
vont être donc dire que c'est un chiffre
élevé déjà un on a rien pour le vérifier
on ne sait pas si c'est un Jules
véritable puisqu'il émane de la campagne
de Trump est-ce que c'est vrai il ne dit
pas que la vérité il nous l'a prouvé et
après ce chiffre n'est pas non plus
énorme comparé assez
Benoîte j'allais dire c'est comment avec
autant d'affaires un candidat aussi
abimé mais ses adversaires que ce soit
au sein du parti républicain ou dans le
camp démocrate n'arrive pas à le pleurer
peut-être le weekend tourne là-dessus
c'est-à-dire que c'est quoi s'il y a une
faiblesse de ses adversaires une
faiblesse inhérente c'est à dire qu'ils
ne peuvent pas l'attaquer frontalement
parce que sinon il s'alienne c'est fan
c'est disc il y a quelque chose de
quasiment religieux dans l'adoration à
Trump donc ils sont dans un jeu
d'équilibriste pourquoi les républicains
pardon nous interrompt pas mais pourquoi
les républicains on va dire historiques
les héritiers de Reagan ou de Trump ils
ont pas disparu du jour au lendemain au
sein de ce parti il y a pas une fenêtre
d'opportunité là juste après le
l'arrivée au pouvoir de de Joe Biden
juste après le l'attaque du Capitole
pour se débarrasser de Donald Trump
c'était pas possible à ce moment-là il y
a eu un moment notamment après les
dernières meeters ou Rhône De Santis
semblait être le renouveau il est
beaucoup plus jeune il a beaucoup moins
de casseroles il est aussi conservateur
donc de ce point de vue là il y a pas de
on perd pas aux changes et une partie de
la presse une partie des gros donateurs
aussi et c'est ça c'est très important
c'est dit peut-être pouvoir tourner la
page et puis finalement on n'a jamais pu
tourner la page il est monté assez haut
dans les sondages Trump s'est présenté
dans une indifférence assez générale en
novembre et puis au fur et à mesure ce
que l'on a vu
c'est que De Santis baissé Trump monter
à chaque inculpation on s'est dit cette
fois-ci ça va le faire descendre et en
fait non et il y a quelque chose
d'inoxydable chez Trump et dans le
soutien de sa base mais on a un
marais dans le dans l'électorat
républicain il y a les trumpistes il y a
les anti Trump et il y a cette espèce de
marée qui est pas totalement hostile ça
ça je comprends bien c'est pour les
républicains et qu'on peut pas s'aliéner
les fans de Donald Trump pour les
démocrates comment ça c'est la personne
chez démocrates qui a été mensuel
oxydable effectivement inoxydable et
irrationnel c'est-à-dire que même avant
quand on pense à sa présidence on a
quand même un président qui a été deux
fois mis en accusation de procédure
c'est quand même quelque chose d'inédit
et pour autant il est aujourd'hui le
candidats qui se rapprolement dominé du
côté républicain donc je pense il y a
vraiment un côté d'irrationnel lui-même
avait dit sous le temps d'une boutade
qui pouvait tuer quelqu'un sur la
Cinquième Avenue et que ça ne remettrait
en rien en cause sa popularité je
répondais juste sur un point vous avez
évoqué la le dilemme pour le système
judiciaire la qui est décrédibilisé à
travers ces mises en accusations mais
effectivement c'est un dilemme parce que
le système judiciaire ne peut pas se
permettre de ne pas réagir face aux
actions Donald Trump donc finalement la
question c'est est-ce que vous créez un
précédent en refusant de lancer des
poursuites au motif que ça fait
augmenter sa popularité politique et je
pense que ça a été la raison pour
laquelle les procédures ont pris un
certain temps les procureurs étaient de
phases d'attendre ne savais pas comment
réagir et paradoxalement c'est le
rapport de la commission d'enquête qui a
poussé les procureurs à agir alors
ensuite côté démocrate la raison pour
tout simplement parce que la société est
extrêmement polarisée donc peu importe
c'est de dire ce que font les démocrates
la base républicaine propre à Donald
Trump ne pourra pas leur être favorable
alors on va continuer de parler des des
alternatives même si elle semble très
affaiblie au sein du parti républicain
et puis peut-être aussi vous donner
quelques clés sur le fonctionnement de
ces primaires on va accueillir tout de
suite
Steve Jourdain pour pour cette chronique
rebonsoir Thomas bienvenue à vous les
primaires comment ça marche et pourquoi
c'est aussi important aux États-Unis
c'est une très grande tradition à la
base des États-Unis ça marche beaucoup
mieux que chez nous en France le
principe est très simple il s'agit de
désigner d'ici à l'été prochain le
candidat des parties républicains et
démocrate qui s'affronteront à la
présidentielle du 5 novembre de l'année
prochaine on vote dans 50 états le
processus s'étend sur 6 mois et les buts
officiellement le 15 janvier autre date
importante Thomas le supertudex
tout à l'heure 15 États votent en même
temps le scrutin aura lieu le 5 mars le
5 mars c'est quoi c'est le lendemain du
début du procès de Donald Trump dans
l'affaire du Capitole cette année
clairement l'enjeu elle est du côté
républicain quoi sauf accident Joe Biden
sera le candidat démocrate oui il y aura
aussi des primaires chez les démocrates
mais elle devrait être de pure forme
Biden président sortant devrait être
investi à nouveau chez les républicains
en revanche attention ça va secouer ils
sont 13 sur la ligne de départ on va
aller voir alors évidemment il y a
Donald Trump qui brille à ce moment-là
son principal challenger on va le voir
c'est Ron De Santis il est où il est
juste en dessous de Donald Trump
gouverneur de Floride depuis 2018 il est
parfois présenté comme un Trump light
dans des idées très radicales avec une
forme un peu plus comme ça présentable
il y a aussi Chris Christie il est tout
à gauche ici sur l'écran ancien
gouverneur du New Jersey ancienne allait
de Trump devenu l'un de ses principaux
détracteurs Nicky Haley seule femme
candidate du côté des républicains on se
souvient qu'elle était ambassadrice
américaine aux Nations unies ou Donald
Trump animal politique redoutable avec
une vraie expérience internationale et
puis vous reconnaissez sans doute Mike
pence mcpens l'ancien vice-président de
Donald Trump sont dans son patron lui
avait demandé d'invalider le résultat
des présidentielles de 2020 il avait
refusé et depuis il est considéré comme
un traître par les partisans de Donald
Trump avec cette impression que tout
dans cette prise dans cette primaire
tourne finalement autour de Donald Trump
oui c'est la grande force de Donald
Trump à tous les candidats sont à
prendre position par rapport à lui tenez
prenez le premier débat télévisé entre
les candidats républicains c'était
mi-août Trump avait décidé de snober
l'exercice il y a eu à peu près deux
heures d'échange on a parlé de tout
dukraine d'inflation d'insécurité et
puis on a parlé surtout presque sur tout
de Donald Trump écouter et si l'ancien
président Donald Trump était condamné
par un tribunal est-ce que vous nous
soutiendrez quand même en tant que
candidat du parti si oui levez la main
vous avez bien entendu sur 8 candidats 6
sont prêts à soutenir Donald Trump il
venait à être condamné par un tribunal
ça vous donne un peu une idée de la
force donnes au sein de ce parti de la
République avec je sais pas sur la bien
vu mais dans cette séquence il y a un
moment qui est désastreux pour une De
Santis si il jette un petit coup d'œil
autour pour voir si les autres lèvent la
main et donc il lève la main lui aussi
merci beaucoup c'est journal pour toutes
ces explications est-ce qu'il peut y
avoir une candidature j'allais dire
sortie de nulle part ça se passe jamais
vraiment vraiment comme ça mais en
dehors de ces primaires républicaines
pour s'adresser quand même à ce à cette
électorat avec lequel oui alors les
candidats ont jusqu'au 15 octobre pour
pour se déclarer
il y a un enfin il y a un ancien
gouverneur du Maryland qui est en
républicain Larry Hogan qui a laissé
planer l'idée mais il la laisse planer
volontairement l'idée qu'il pourrait se
présenter au titre de son groupe dont il
est membre fondateurs ça veut dire pas
l'étiquette donc un groupe transpartisan
qui ferait concurrence en fait que dire
Hogan Hogan il fait partie de ses
républicains que vous mentionnez tout à
l'heure qui sont très contrariés par la
situation actuelle du parti et qui veut
que les candidats se réunissent autour
d'une figure contre Trump il y a
beaucoup trop de candidats aujourd'hui
Trump est devant parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de candidats déclarés à la
primaire et donc ils sont
extraordinairement divisés en plus du
fait qu'ils sont ils ont moins de
notoriété et moins de charisme donc
Hogan lui il veut faire gagner son camp
parce que Trump est certes en position
de gagner les primaires mais
certainement pas en position gagner les
élections générales donc
Hogan lance un message et dit maintenant
il faut se réunir parce que les
adversaires ou ceux qui sont
pas fans de Trump sont assez nombreux
dans le parti et pourraient faire un
contrepoids alors sur les élections
générales on peut on peut y venir parce
qu'on a on est évoqué avec Olivier
Python et je leur donnerai la parole
dans un instant le finalement les
indépendants c'est quoi sont les
électeurs qui font basculer une élection
aux États-Unis sans doute aussi un peu
la même chose partout mais qu'est-ce
qu'ils pensent de Trump et de ses
affaires aujourd'hui alors ça dépend le
problème c'est que ils sont décisifs et
pourtant c'est ceux qui s'intéressent le
moins la politique qui se sont ceux qui
votent le moins et pourtant c'est eux
qui sont décisifs qu'est-ce qu'ils
pensent généralement économiquement ils
sont plutôt conservateurs républicains
notamment fiscalement mieux pour eux ils
pensent que les républicains sont
meilleurs en business l'emploi etc et en
même temps point de vue sociétal ils
sont plutôt progressistes donc si
l'avortement par exemple
sans creux véritablement comme pomme de
discorde centrale de la campagne ils
voteront plutôt démocrate donc voilà
c'est vraiment des gens qui sont
tiraillés entre les deux il y a des gens
qui ont voté Obama puis Trump et puis
qui sont revenus à Biden il y a des gens
qui tergent d'hiver il y a des gens qui
votent peu et ont surtout on vote contre
donc on va pas forcément voter Biden
parce qu'il est génial mais peut-être
voter Biden parce qu'il est moins pire
que Trump donc c'est là-dessus que
l'élection va se faire plus sur le
désinvestissement le désengagement
c'est-à-dire qui va faire voter ses
fidèles le plus est-ce que c'est Trump
ou est-ce qu'il va perdre un petit peu
certains républicains où est-ce que
Biden va perdre les minorités par
exemple parce que
Olivier python votre avis là-dessus et
peut-être sur l'intérêt des Américains
pour un match retour entre Biden et et
Trump est-ce que il y a eu beaucoup de
participation au précédent scrutin
est-ce qu'on risque c'est peut-être trop
tôt pour le dire évidemment mais d'avoir
une sorte de désaffection pour pour ce
match retour qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez alors il y a plusieurs choses
dans ce qui a été dit la première
effectivement il y a une il y a une
vraie désaffection à l'égard du duel qui
s'annonce entre Joe bidon et Donald
Trump vous avez une écrasante majorité
un peu plus des deux tiers des
Américains qui ne souhaitent pas que son
on se retrouve de nouveau dans la
configuration de 2020
deuxièmement sur les indépendants il y a
un chiffre qui est intéressant c'est que
environ 60% des indépendants qui sont en
interroger disque dans Zoo dans nous
aucun cas il ne voteront Donald Trump
donc il y a une sorte de plafond de
verre vis-à-vis de Donald Trump du côté
des indépendants qui ne voteront pas
Donald Trump mais le problème ne se
n'est pas réglé pour autant la réalité
n'est pas tellement de savoir si les
indépendants sont pour ou contre Donald
Trump que de savoir si les indépendants
vont se déplacer pour aller voter pour
Joe Biden parce que Joe Biden a aussi
ses problèmes et en particulier son âge
et vous avez tout à fait la possibilité
de vous retrouver dans une configuration
qui serait une configuration finalement
assez classique où les plus mobilisés
vont voter et au bout du compte le camp
le plus mobilisé gagnerait l'élection
parce que les modérée n'iraient pas se
rendre à Lyon tout simplement parce
qu'il considérait pour tout un tas de
raisons que ça ne les concerne pas et là
grosse difficulté c'est que depuis
effectivement quelques semaines pointe
également parce qu'on parle beaucoup de
Trump mais il y a également son
adversaire Joe Biden on parlait
énormément aussi de l'âge du capitaine
et toute la clé du côté des indépendants
c'est d'aller les faire voter pour Joe
Biden il ne vautrons pas forcément pour
Donald Trump en majorité ce
déplaceront-ils pour voter pour Joe
Biden c'est pas du tout évident et ce
serait l'une des clés la principale clé
de l'élection à venir si Donald Trump
évidemment remportait les primaires
alors Donald Trump il lance aussi un
défi au constitutionnaliste avec
l'alinéa 3 du 14e amendement alors on va
pas le lire en entier on a essayé de le
résumer nul ne sera sénateur ou
représentant au congrès ou électeur des
présidents et vice-présidents ni
occupera aucune charge civile ou
unitaire du gouvernement des États-Unis
après avoir pris part à une insurrection
ou à une rébellion contre eux ou donner
aide ou secours à leurs ennemis
idrissent face assis cet article de la
Constitution peut-il empêcher Donald
Trump d'exercer un éventuel seconde
mandat ou alors même de se présenter à
l'élection alors théoriquement oui et
c'est intéressant depuis quelques
semaines c'était un article à l'origine
vivent attention parce que des membres
importants de la doctrine juridique des
conservateurs ont pris position en
disant effectivement que en vertu de sa
disposition dans la trappe est éligible
il y a plusieurs difficultés c'est à
dire c'est une disposition qui a été
très peu mobilisé dans les prétoirs donc
très peu utilisé par les cours de
justice et jurisprudence
ancienne mais qui n'est pas d'accord
suprême et c'est encore une fois
l'illustration du caractère inédit de la
présidence Trump c'est-à-dire que et de
l'après président sont se pose et
question qu'on se posait pas est-ce
qu'un président peut se glacier lui-même
est-ce qu'un président est-ce qu'un
candidat peut être emprison au moment de
son action et donc là c'est une nouvelle
question il y a deux points importants
tout d'abord de qualification comment
est-ce qu'on qualifie la rébellion et
l'insurrection et là il y a des bas et
surtout qui le fait c'est-à-dire est-ce
que ce sont des cours qui le font ou
est-ce que et ça c'est une théorie
émergente est-ce que n'importe quel
agent c'est à dire des personnes qui
doivent vérifier par exemple lorsqu'on
met les noms sur les bulletins de vote
que parce qu'il y a des conditions pour
être président il faut avoir 35 ans par
exemple et en vertu cette nouvelle
théorie chacun pourrait dire
effectivement non Donald Trump ne peut
pas être sur le butin de vote parce
qu'il s'est parlé je voulais voir les
conditions 35 ans né aux États-Unis
avoir hésité aux États-Unis pendant
exactement et la grosse difficulté c'est
que 250 c'est factuel on peut déterminer
est-ce que quelqu'un s'est engagé dans
une insurrection de rébellion là il y a
des bas justement et donc mon avis
personnel et que il semble difficile de
laisser chaque agent se prononcer en la
matière et donc on en revient à ce qui a
une caractéristique du régime américain
une décision par une cour et la Cour
suprême d'accord donc il faudra que ce
soit tranchée exactement il est possible
avant avant
les gens qui vont faire des recours en
disant que Donald Trump ne peut pas être
inscrit sur un bouton de vote mais alors
donc on a vu ces conditions mais il y a
pas de restriction sur les poursuites
pénales ou même un passage en prison
c'est alors c'est un très vieil exemple
mais la présidentielle de 1920 candidats
qui étaient condamné pour sédition avait
mené campagne derrière les barreaux il
avait fini 3e et est-ce que Olivier
python cette envisageable dans le 4mp ou
alors c'est totalement de la politique
fiction que je suis en train de faire
est-ce qu'il pourrait mener campagne
depuis sa prison
oui oui ça fait partie des charmes de la
du droit constitutionnel américain du
droit électoral américain sauf dans
quatre états et la Géorgie n'en fait pas
partie il est possible un candidat
d'être
incarcéré de mener campagne et mettre
des élus la géologie est un cas
particulier ça fait partie du Vieux Sud
et donc de cette espèce de
d'opposition de méfiance à l'égard du
pouvoir central et de Washington en
particulier la Géorgie est un état on ne
peut pas s'auto
donc si Donald Trump était condamné par
l'État de Géorgie ni lui-même président
élu ni le gouverneur de Géorgie ne
pourrait l'amnister donc on est dans les
cas de figure ce qui est absolument
génial c'est qu'on est dans un hommage
lampes juridique à tout point de vue et
que à chaque fois on avance vers quelque
chose d'inédit et pour en venir à
l'instant si vous me le permettez sur le
fameux alinéa 3 de l'amendement 14 qui a
été dit et tout à fait juste à dire que
on a une véritable bataille d'experts
pour savoir si on pourrait l'utiliser ou
pas mais avant cela
la qualification et la condamnation pour
rébellion et pour insurrection doit être
absolument ary ou doit arriver à terme
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut que Donald Trump
soit condamné pour qu'effectivement
puisse éventuellement utiliser l'article
le troisième alinéa de la du 14e
amendement de la Constitution on en est
pas là et de toute façon on le sait
maintenant son accident c'est la Cour
suprême qui au bout du compte jouera les
juges de paix c'est le cas de le dire et
décidera de la validité ou non le cas
échéant si Donald Trump est condamné sur
ces points là de savoir si il a le droit
de se présenter ou pas en vertu de cet
article de la cet amendement de la
Constitution alors on va voir en quoi
finalement la personnalité la stratégie
et puis toutes ces affaires judiciaires
qui qui caractérise l'action politique
de Donald Trump quel défi pour la
démocratie américaine mais aussi quelles
leçons pour les politiques du monde
entier Mathieu je me tourne vers vous
parce que vous voulez demander en quoi
Donald Trump influencer ou un inf
renforcer la politique française c'est
pas facile parce qu'il y a pas personne
en France qui se réclame ouvertement du
trumpisme dans notre classe politique
mais quand même le style les méthodes et
parfois les certaines idées de
l'expédience des États-Unis ont quand
même laissé des traces ou infuser
notamment dans le débat public tous les
je vous montre un exemple qui est le
plus connu l'exemple de celui qui en
était le plus proche dans le style dans
sa dernière campagne présidentielle
Eric Zemmour regardez c'est la
couverture de son livre de campagne la
France n'a pas dit son dernier mot ça
c'était pendant la dernière campagne
présidentielle et regardez un peu de qui
il s'inspirait again évidemment le livre
de Donald Trump paru en 2016 qui lui
aussi posait devant un drapeau mais
au-delà le même directeur artistique
mais pas loin on voit bien et
Eric Zemmour d'ailleurs ne s'en était
pas caché mais au-delà du cas du
président de reconquête il y a au moins
quatre éléments qui me semblent avoir
largement infusé dans notre débat public
alors on va aller lister lesquels alors
la posture anti-système d'abord dans nos
démocraties occidentales fatiguées
Donald Trump a montré que la posture
anti-système c'était la clé pour parler
à des électeurs lacets avec évidemment
un style populiste c'était le sien
qu'importe qu'on vient du système
d'ailleurs Donald Trump en été
l'essentiel c'est de jouer la disruption
et de promettre de renverser la table
avec ce vieux monde avec ce dont on ne
veut plus entendre parler et pour le
coup il est pas anodin de remarquer
qu'en 2017 les trois candidats
arrivaient en tête de la présidentielle
française chacun leur manière je ne
parle pas de Claude de Donald Trump je
prends bien de précaution mais était
dans une posture anti-système Emmanuel
Macron Marine Le Pen Jean-Luc Mélenchon
second à mon avis élément la pause
vérité l'effet alternatives on peut les
appeler comme on veut c'est majeur ça
c'est majeur parce que l'élection Donald
Trump a quand même montré qu'on pouvait
largement s'arranger avec les faits voir
les tordre dans un pays qui jusque là
abhorait le parjure et le mensonge en
tout cas c'est du moins ce qu'on pensait
comme le résumé l'écrivain Giuliano dans
Pauline dans son ouvrage Les ingénieurs
du chaos plusieurs vérités
contradictoires peuvent coexister sans
que l'une infirme nécessairement l'autre
voilà ce qui est devenu le débat aux
êtres politiques aux États-Unis mais
parfois aussi on a l'impression le débat
français qui a son lot de fake news on
en a vu relayer sur les réseaux sociaux
notamment dont le fonctionnement de ces
réseaux sociaux en vaselot empêche
précisément à la vérité d'émerger ou au
mensonges d'être mis à jour alors il y a
aussi le rapport aux médias le rapport
au média parce que Trump ne sait pas
fait élire sans les médias en tout cas
il en avait un à peu près on s'est
lequel mais c'est largement fait élire
contre les médias et ça c'est quand même
assez nouveau et il a utilisé les
réseaux sociaux comme une arme politique
qui lui permettait de s'adresser
directement
de ces électeurs son filtre en France
aussi mais plusieurs personnalités
politiques s'en sont inspirées alors en
tout cas n'hésitez pas à s'en prendre
aux médias traditionnel avec beaucoup
d'agressivité ou souvenez peut-être des
mots avec pointant son son fusil en
riant au salon mini-pol lors de la
dernière campagne présidentielle ou de
d'autres candidats qui s'en sont pris
très agressivement avec beaucoup
d'agressivité au milieu traditionnelles
et puis beaucoup aussi ont tenté de les
contourner en faisant leur propre canaux
de diffusion et on s'adressant
directement à leur public sur les
réseaux sociaux et puis dernière élément
sans doute l'agressivité verbale alors
là vous allez me dire la France voilà
n'a pas attendu Donald Trump pour voir
ses politiques échanger des noms
d'oiseaux mais quand même moi je trouve
que l'agressivité verbale de Donald
Trump c'est propos sexistes ces attaques
le niveau de ses attaques contre ces
concurrents et et ses adversaires on
fait croire à beaucoup que le parler
vrai ben passer par une nécessaire
surenchère et qu'il suffisait de hausser
le ton et il faut se dire aussi qu'en
France on a vu dans le débat public des
noms de plus en plus forts des attaques
de plus en plus vives entre les
différents cand là où entre les
différents personnels politiques
regardez un peu ce qui s'est passé à
l'Assemblée nationale sur des bas des
retraites c'était quand même assez
nouveau l'invective avait remplacé
l'argument alors c'est vrai que ça fait
plus de bruit et que ça coûte moins cher
et beaucoup en France dans tous les
partis ont quand même retenu cette leçon
là est-ce qu'il y a un risque de
contagion pour vous moi je suis
convaincu que on est quand même face à
un affaiblissement de nos démocraties et
que finalement la victoire de Trump et
son attitude actuelle contribue encore à
cet affaiblissement est-ce que vous
parlez d'un risque contagieux ou pas non
je pense que Donald Trump est un produit
et non un facteur
cette vague populiste qui traverse
toutes les démocraties occidentales on
la voit depuis plus de 25 ans donc on
sait que il y a une crise de la
représentation dans les démocraties
occidentales c'est à dire une
désaffection progressive pour les
parties traditionnelles de gouvernement
à droite comme à gauche
un électorat qui se transforme qui se
reconnaît de moins en moins de ces
parties traditionnelles qui ne se
réalisent pas sur les préférences de
leur électorat donc Trump et le produit
de ça il est il est le produit de partie
traditionnelle qui ont déçu qui ne
répondent plus à leurs électeurs que ce
soit le parti démocrate qui s'est
complètement désolée de la walking class
des Américains moyens entre guillemets
je dis ça bien sûr sans connotation
péjorative et le parti républicain qui
aujourd'hui n'a quasiment pas de
plateforme programmatique n'a pas de
programme donc si Trump existe c'est pas
parce qu'il a émergé et qu'il a renversé
la table c'est parce que c'était le
chaos qu'il est arrivé mais alors votre
avis aussi l'origine ton parce que vous
nous disiez tout à l'heure c'était
presque votre premier intervention un
peu la même chose moi je me suis moins
optimiste que vous quoi j'ai finalement
j'ai peur que Trump fasse des des petits
et que cette démocratie américaine elle
continue de s'affaiblir il y a deux
choses la partie sont historiquement
faibles car très peu et très mal
organisé aux États-Unis c'est pas du
tout des grosses machines il n'y a pas
de carte face à des coquilles vides il y
a beaucoup d'argent dans les campagnes
mais pas dans les parties et ils sont
détestés par l'opinion donc la première
victoire de Trump celle qui a mis le
plus longtemps à se dessiner en
2015-2016 c'était contre un parti
républicain dont il a complètement
retourné la doctrine sur le
libre-échange sur l'interventionnisme
etc au passage donc là c'était le la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
qu'il y a une aspiration à un retour à
quelque chose de normal ce qui peut
sembler paradoxal parce qu'en même temps
il reste en tête de la campagne
imaginons que pour une raison ou une
autre plutôt de santé Trump sort et on a
quelqu'un qui est
désigné ou élu comme Nicky Halie par
exemple ou team Scott qui sont beaucoup
plus apaisés et bien là on pourrait
avoir une sorte de changement du climat
vers quelque chose de plus apaisé on a
vu qu'il y avait un certain nombre de
candidats qu'on a appelé des bébés Trump
qui ont essayé de faire du ou en tout
cas de faire du Trump mais ça n'a pas
forcément toujours bien marché quand ils
sont dans un terroir qui est très
républicain ils vont être élu parce
qu'ils sont républicains pas parce
qu'ils sont trumpiste et on en a vu
d'autres comme Lauren bobberd par
exemple qui est une jeune femme du
Colorado qui a eu beaucoup de mal à se
faire réélire dans un coin qui est très
républicain du Colorado alors qu'elle
fait du super Trump donc c'est pas
forcément très porteur votre avis sur le
vous avez en partie répondu sur la
justice tout à l'heure qui est un des
piliers de la démocratie mais plus
généralement effectivement moi je pense
que les leçons de l'expérience
américaine c'est des années c'est
véritablement à qui fait en confiance
pour faire obstacle pour s'opposer à ses
libertés autoritaire et au premier abord
on pourrait se dire mais on peut faire
confiance aux institutions politiques
c'est à dire le Congrès le Congrès a
failli pour des raisons de solidarité
partisanes les pitch point on l'a vu il
a été mise en accusation mais ensuite
les senteurs républicains on fait passer
le parti finalement avant la
Constitution ensuite on pourrait se dire
mais finalement les juges c'est si parce
qu'aujourd'hui mais on voit bien en
sorte de cercle vicieux puisque
aujourd'hui l'argument des républicains
et de dire on ne peut pas laisser Trump
être condamné puisqu'il est le candidat
de notre partie et ce serait génial
gérance dans le système politique et
finalement je pense que le dernier mot
reviendra aux électeurs et malgré les le
nombre d'affaires importants qui sont là
c'est aujourd'hui je pense que il n'y
aura pas de condamnation avant
l'élection et que le dernier mot
reviendra aux électeurs Mathieu les
médias c'est plus le cadre d'un pouvoir
on a vu effectivement et ça utilise tout
à l'heure avec l'élection 2016 la
court-circuité les médias et dans les
domaines sont propres média tout d'abord
il y a Twitter donc aujourd'hui je pense
que Trump a court-circuité cet ancien
système cet ancien monde tel qu'il
pouvait discover peut-être qui soutenait
Trump qui s'en était éloignés en jouant
peut-être la carte run De Santis et il
en le média en est où aujourd'hui
vis-à-vis de Donald Trump ce média n'est
ne soutient plus Donald Trump et
réciproquement on l'a vu par exemple
avec la contre-interview qui avait donné
Donald Trump à Tokyo Carlson le soir du
débat des primaires républicaines donc
tocardson un animateur vedette viré de
Fox News et Donald Trump
news complètement donc non mais
effectivement les réseaux sociaux au
prix aussi un pouvoir en tout cas une
visibilité
bien supérieure à ce que ça pouvait être
il y a encore quelques années en arrière
donc Donald Trump utilise les canaux qui
sont à sa disposition et reprendre
d'ailleurs des des vieux discours qu'on
a déjà entendu même en France faut se
souvenir de Jean-Marie Le Pen dans les
années 80 qui disait que tous les médias
étaient contre lui que personne voulait
le recevoir donc ces discours là on les
connaît on les entend depuis longtemps
mais là il y a d'autres outils qui
existent et tout le monde
est connecté au web et les minorités
actives sont très
proactives dans la
diffusion de nouvelles qui leur sont
favorables Olivier python on pourrait
faire une liste vous parliez du Congrès
finalement fragilisé on pourrait dire la
Cour suprême aussi dont les dont les
avis ont été perçus comme trop politisés
là ça allait vraiment contre une
tradition
américaine bon là on parlait de la
justice je repose sur un peu têtu mais
je repose la question sur cette
démocratie américaine qui a souvent été
donnée en modèle à un peu partout dans
le monde est-ce que vous vous êtes
optimiste ou pessimiste est-ce que vous
dites de toute façon elle survivra à
cette tornade Trump ou alors est-ce que
elle se fragilise durablement
un peu des deux un peu des deux d'abord
la crise de la démocratie telle qu'on la
perçoit aujourd'hui c'est d'abord
fondamentalement une crise de la classe
moyenne d'abord il y a eu la classe ce
qu'on appelle les walking class donc les
classes les plus pauvérisées qui ont
abandonné le vote et qui ont grossi les
rangs de l'abstention en particulier à
partir des années 90 et c'est valable
dans tout l'Occident et pas simplement
aux États-Unis et là maintenant depuis
une dizaine d'années pour tout un tas de
raisons on assiste à une paupérisation
et donc à une crise de la classe moyenne
et cette paupérisation et cette crise de
la classe moyenne va de pair avec ce
qu'on appelle une crise de la démocratie
c'est-à-dire le refus du du langage
raisonnable le refus du discours que
l'on pourrait qualifier de rationnel
pour un discours alternatif un discours
beaucoup plus militant beaucoup plus
table rase et c'est là-dessus que je
suis complètement d'accord avec ce qu'a
dit elisachel tout à l'heure Donald
Trump pour parler de lui et davantage
une conséquence un symptôme qu'une
réelle cause donc la crise à mon avis la
crise de la démocratie c'est une crise
de la représentation de la
représentativité elle passera d'abord
par le règlement du problème que connaît
actuellement la classe moyenne dans son
ensemble on est sorti des trentes
glorieuses depuis maintenant longtemps
et on est face à une crise qui est une
crise globale qui est véritablement une
crise interne et qui dont on voit
aujourd'hui les prémices aux États-Unis
mais qui est évidemment valable en
France ou d'ailleurs on a une
augmentation constante du taux de
l'abstention et cela va également
corroborer ce narratif là mais dans
cette crise démocratique et je me tourne
vers vous le week-end temps il y a quand
même
l'acceptation du résultat d'une élection
je vous propose de regarder les
résultats d'un sondage c'est un sondage
yugov qui avait été réalisé pour la
chaîne CBS il y a quelques il y a
quelques mois puisqu'on était au mois de
juin de cette année juste avant les
vacances
70% des républicains je suis précis des
électeurs républicains estiment que
Biden n'a pas été élu de quels sont
légitime
c'est quand même certes ce sont que les
républicains je sais pas le jugement de
valeur quand je dis ça mais c'est quand
même majeur comme comme proportion donc
là il y a un affaiblissement du résultat
de l'élection l'acceptation des
résultats si c'est pas un pilier du
démocratie c'est quoi absolument le sens
de la question et est intéressant quand
on creuse un petit peu il y a un certain
nombre de ces gens qui disent et c'est
il y a un spectre il y a les
ultrastrumpis qui disent que de toute
façon tout a été faussé c'est un complot
etc et il y a un certain nombre de gens
qui sont dans ce bloc là des 70 qui
disent il y a quand même des choses
qu'on ne sait pas il y a des choses
suspectes il y a des choses qu'on ne
saura jamais j'ai entendu que j'ai lu
que il y a un certain nombre de faits
alternatifs ou pas qui font que voilà il
y a un certain nombre de gens qui ont
probablement voté alors qu'ils
n'auraient pas dû et on ne saura jamais
on ne pourra jamais l'objectiver on en
saura jamais si c'est vrai ou pas parce
que 2020 c'était une élection un petit
peu spéciale qui a eu des dispositions
qui dans certains États ont été changés
un petit que la dernière minute parce
qu'il y avait un petit peu le sujet du
covid quand même donc il fallait adapter
la démocratie au contexte sanitaire et
donc avec ces adaptations parfois un
petit peu de dernière minute il y a les
républicains qui disent ah mais attendez
si on change les règles au dernier
moment qui vote vraiment qui a le droit
de voter etc donc il y a cette espèce de
soupçon qui rentre dans la question de
la légitimité du vote Biden et qui
s'agglomère avec des gens qui rejettent
totalement ce qui est de plus en plus
nouveau mais aussi de plus en plus fort
le fait que n'importe qui d'autre que
Trump puisse être élu merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce à ce
débat j'ai rappelé le titre de votre
livre Le weekendton il sort le 21
septembre aux éditions Hors Collection
on va parler musique rock n' road trip
1000 chansons de l'Alabama au Wyoming
coécrit avec Julien Grosso et puis
Olivier python je n'oublie pas que vous
avez publié ce portrait de Kamala Harris
la pionnière de l'Amérique livre publié
aux éditions
plomb merci à tous encore une fois je
vous dis à bientôt sur le plateau de
public c'est la voilà c'est là fin de ce
numéro de sciences publiques merci à
toutes et à tous de votre fidélité on se
retrouve demain 18h 22h sur Public Sénat
belle soirée
[Musique]